leavon uh welcome back to the show the
last time we uh had you you made aw last
year okay that's mean that is very mean
of you but you said that you're looking
to learn in these very tense situations
and today I have to say it feels like
we've seen the old leevon back in the
game just an impressive Victory from you
how are you feeling right
now I'm very good uh you know because uh
I I was uh not too optimistic with my
tournament cuz I've been uh just not
getting a play and today as well I think
he kind of tricked me with the move
order so I had to settle for this bishop
E3 very obviously I mean it's not uh not
a very manly way to play but I thought
uh I mean if I allow him to play KN D to
G5 you know I I didn't remember what I
what I really intended there but then I
got lucky cuz my opponent uh blundered
then Knight takes on E5 and then uh in
this complication it seems that white
should be better and uh somehow um I I
managed to convert that Advantage so you
mean at this point obviously it was a
big blunder with the move Bishop to E6
and we could see it was this a shocking
moment for you because we know Sam for
so many years he's not a player that
generally blunders in this
fashion oh yeah of course I mean it's
very very surprising CU he's a he's a
very knowledgeable very consistent and u
a very good player absolutely but it
still required uh some Precision for you
to convert because he was trying to make
it difficult this move Knight to G4
trying to change uh the D Dynamic of the
position but you did find this idea of
F3 Queen to E1 I think this was a very
powerful move give us your thoughts um
about this position and this particular
sequence yeah I couldn't really figure
figure out if if I should settle for D
and take on F7 or should I settle for
this position it's very difficult to
understand which one is actually uh you
mean this one and take on F7 yeah cuz
this is also kind of interesting a great
Advantage takes and Knight C4 Knight E5
I saw this stuff uh but but I told to
myself you know I don't
know what if what if uh what if it's
nothing and and I'll regret it so I
thought not to spend too much time
thinking and I saw this F3 Queen E1 C4
should be slightly better for me cuz I
play Knight E4 uh and queen D4 came as a
surprise actually the the move that he
played because I thought uh instead he
should play play Knight H5 and the
position is far from Clear course uh you
know I mean it's better for me but after
Queen D4 it's already that um I have no
chance to go wrong you know I'm more or
less uh uh playing in a safe and and in
Joyful Joyful mood here no absolutely
and you show that with your last
tournament few moves uh to finish off uh
the tournament still one round to go
still plenty of chances coming your way
for sure but we were talking about this
position and yaser was telling us this
story about inviting all of your friends
to the party you are definitely inviting
all of your friends on this side to the
party and uh you did all the way until
there was a coronation congratul Leon
we'll see you tomorrow thank you thank
you FKS yeah our congratulations to uh
leavon I'm going to jump quickly to the
game of hot